what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so normally mondays are reserved for
all-new all-different marvel this is
where we cover you know story arcs are
going on in Marvel Comics right now but
after reading amazing spider-man number
21 which featured the return of Scarlet
Spider Kane it also gave us a lot of
information in terms of what Kane has
been doing and what it did is it
basically reveal the existence of the
carrion virus now the carrion virus is
something that has existed for quite
some time
but in terms of what Dan slots doing
right now with amazing spider-man it
basically seems like he's using the
carrion concept from superior spider-man
and so what I wanted to do here is
basically cover this little bit of a
story there's not a whole lot going on
here but it really gives us a general
idea of what to expect in terms of how
the virus exists and how it goes from
person to person so for those of you
guys who know about superior spider-man
bear with me for a second because
there's a lot of people who don't so
superior spider-man is kind of
considered to be like the quintessential
run of Dan Slott it's really the story
that Dan Slott used to establish the
fact that he could create something
wholly unique and new that hadn't really
been seen before and what I mean is that
there have been instances where Peter
Parker has stopped being spider-man
sometimes he's given it up sometimes you
know we had things like the aftermath of
the Clone Saga where Ben Reilly became
spider-man who said of Peter Parker
there's been instances where this has
happened but there's never really been
an instance where Peter Parker's body
has been taken from him for any real
measure of time and that's what superior
spider-man did it created a scenario
whereby Doctor Octopus had basically put
his mind in the body of Peter Parker now
if you guys are interested I can do a
little more of an explanation on
superior spider-man at a later date but
the idea here is that for the sake of
this story this is the first team-up
line of stories for superior spider-man
which shows us how he acts with his own
team and in conjunction with the
Avengers in terms of earning their trust
but the idea here is that we initially
pick up with cloak and dagger now cloak
and dagger are very street-level
characters they're very small times are
not wildly important to this story they
do have somewhat of a fanbase but again
for this moment right now we don't
really need to focus on them all we
really need to know is that they have
come across several criminals who are
basically in the process of attempting
to rob some some innocent individuals
but in the midst of this in the midst of
their attempt to stop this robbery
they're suddenly met by the arrival of
superior spider-man now of course their
responses hey man
have this you know you don't have to
show up to this but instead of you know
more or less walking away he basically
beats them up and pummels them into into
submission and so from here we basically
jump to superior spider-man fighting
daredevil now we're really given this in
a very fast pace we're not given a whole
lot of information here and the reason
why is because following these two
attacks we switch over to Captain
America in Avengers tower of course
being being aided by Jarvis and we
essentially get him watching all these
different news reports where different
people are reporting that Spider Man
seems to have gone awry that he's gone
gone rogue and been attacking both a
hero and villain alike and Steve Rogers
essentially brings together the entirety
of the Avengers now the reason why this
is necessary for Steve Rogers to do is
because spider-man's no joke granted
spider-man's not one of the most
powerful beings in existence but his
spider sense is really like the one
thing that makes him that give him the
ability to stand on his own against a
multitude of different villains that
exists out there who would otherwise
kill him but we also learned is that
he's gone against a multitude of
individuals and he's shown absolutely no
remorse whatsoever he's taken them all
on and he spot every single one of them
and so the Avengers or I guess led by
Captain America essentially say they
need to take down spider-man now again
because a lot of this is given to us in
really quick succession there's not a
whole lot to really go on here except to
say that various members of the Avengers
and various superheroes in general try
to take them on where they can of course
we have Power Man and Iron Fist we have
a son girl we have Moon Knight we have
Doctor Strange but all of them are
easily defeated in turn now the other
half of this is that this is Doctor
Octopus spider-man so he's able to use
the powers of Peter Parker I guess use
the powers of spider-man in ways that
Peter Parker would have never thought of
before or in ways it a little more
ingenuitive compared to what Peter
Parker would have thought of before but
again you know we essentially have a
scenario where it seems as though every
single superhero who's either part of
the Avengers part of the Fantastic Four
part of the Inhumans or whatever are all
trying to take out spider-man as best
they can and so where he seems to be
getting away at every turn where he
seems to be taking them out we also
learn there's a little more going on
here with regards to the carrion virus
itself now initially he's match or I
guess you know after all this is done
and he's fought all these superheroes
he's met by the Incredible Hulk
by Black Widow Captain America Hawkeye
Hyperion and so on the Hyperion is the
key here because Hyperion's will
like the brunt of the character in this
story The Incredible Hulk again does
what he can against against spider-man
but his agility easily allows him to to
evade his every step until Thor steps
into the fray after which he's basically
taken prisoner by both Thor and The
Incredible Hulk now while spider-man
does have extreme strength while he does
pull his punches when it comes to
villains with regards to the Incredible
Hulk and Thor there's no contest here I
mean there's there's no real offering
that spider-man can bring to the table
when it comes to taking on either one of
these guys not only that when he's
questioned by by Steve Rogers and by
Iron Man he basically says hey look
there's this virus or some kind of thing
a sentience of sorts that's jumping from
person to person and is taking over
their bodies we don't know what the plan
of this thing is but it's moving from
person to person and it seems to be
taking them over and using it for its
own purposes now what he also says is
that the the clean suit basically that
the cleanroom environment of the
interior of Tony Stark's suit is
designed to keep out bacteria keep out
viruses and so it's likely that he'll be
safe but what he does is he basically
begin scanning the bodies of the
Avengers who are here in order to make
sure that none of them are infected and
when he does he basically comes to the
realization that Hyperion is infected
now again the reason why I offered the
title of Hyperion I guess is being you
know Marvel Superman is because model
has like three different version of
Superman I mean Hyperion's the closest
when it comes to origins he's the son of
a dying civilization from another
reality he was sent from that planet he
arrived in the main Marvel Universe he
took up residence and became a superhero
century is close he's close to Superman
when it comes to like unbridled strength
and Adam Brashear is close to Superman
when it comes to both strength and
intelligence but the kicker about this
is that Superman's like the first
superhero so essentially anybody with
flight with super speed with
super-strength and a cape could be a
pawned off as essentially being a copy
of Superman it's an unavoidable thing I
mean in truth - the Cape we could say
the Carol Danvers is a copy of Superman
it's not that Marvel is intending to do
this it's that it just worked out this
way because of the standard that
Superman said in terms of the existence
of superheroes and how they relate to
the overall superhero community in terms
of their powers and abilities and so on
and so forth now the other half of this
is it because Hyperion is so strong and
because Hyperion is so capable
The Avengers can't do anything the
Avengers have nothing to offer against
Hyperion because of the fact that he's
so powerful and in fact he takes them
all apart piece by piece this is really
just a display of power it's really just
to show a force in terms of what it is
in ipiria is capable of kind of mugging
your marvel reminding us hey just in
case you forgot Hyperion is one of the
most powerful beings in the Marvel
Universe right now just in terms of
sheer strength now what we have in
response to this is essentially superior
spider-man grabbing a gun that he's
created now this isn't just any random
gun it said it's been designed
explicitly by Doctor Octopus for the
purpose of neutralizing this virus for
the purpose of basically taking this
virus at least it seems as though the
idea is to destroy this virus in its
entirety and so while we have you know
Doctor Octopus superior spider-man doing
what he can to get this weapon prepared
we basically have Hulk and we have Carol
Danvers trying to buy time now of course
when it comes to the Incredible Hulk
he's really kind of an enigma we're not
really in an igneous kind of a wild-card
here in the sense of the stronger he
gets the angrier he gets and so this is
really one of those questions of who
would win Superman versus The Incredible
Hulk um you know it would have to be
something where the incredible hope was
beat right off the bat in order to
ensure that his anger wouldn't increase
his strength leading to basically a
stalemate between two like an
unstoppable force meeting an immovable
object but again because this is Doctor
Octopus because of the fact that this
weapon is designed for the purpose of
neutralizing the virus
he immediately fires it on Hyperion and
is able to cleanse him of the virus
itself what he also says is that this is
his idea it's basically to eliminate
this virus to make sure that it never
comes back now again the main belief
here from Doctor Octopus are from
superior spider-man anyway so the virus
has been destroyed at least to his mind
it's it's gone in its entirety and so
what we learn is that this is really
like his first step in gaining the trust
of the Avengers and getting the
superhero community team to believe he
was a good guy now the other half of
this is that as far as I'm aware this is
before Doctor Octopus basically turns
over a new leaf
and decides to be a good guy the reason
why I say that is when dr. octopus first
took over the body of Peter Parker and
became spider-man he was like a bad guy
he's like I can do anything now you know
I can take out virtually anybody I can
defeat anybody you know I can form my
own team and the reason why I can defeat
all these people is because they'll
trust me you know if I earn their trust
they'll believe that I'm genuinely a
good guy and they in turn will not
suspect the fact that I would turn
against them and so he basically makes
the case that he
really callin the Avengers he can't
really call in the x-men yes they're
there but he needs his own formidable
team
he needs a tomb of his own to be able to
help him carry out his campaigns against
the various you know heroes that are out
there and so the last little tidbit here
really kind of wraps back around into
the idea of the carrion virus in terms
of how it exists in the clone conspiracy
right now in in the spider-man series by
Dan Slott when we have a new carrion
essentially show up to jackal this is
when we learn that jackal had created
the carrion virus for the purpose of
presumably killing spider-man that the
idea was to basically jump from one host
body to the next until it could come
across a being powerful enough to kill
spider-man you know by taking over his
his spider since the so on and so forth
but again you know this is not a super
important story this is really one of
those instances where I just wanted to
throw it out there for the purpose of
having a more cohesive understanding of
what's going on with the Garcia clone
conspiracy at the moment so what I'll do
is I'll go ahead and throw this in the
playlist for Amazing Spiderman that
playlist I have some things in there
it's not wildly complete we really you
know we really need to go back and do
the first three or four volumes or so of
the all-new all-different Amazing
Spiderman in order to add some more meat
and potatoes to it really but for the
time being you know for those of you
guys who were picking up from clone
conspiracy Pro amazing spider-man number
21 which came out this week hopefully
you guys have a better understanding of
how the carrion virus fits into
everything that's going on but if you
guys are new here to commerce explain
make sure you guys I hit the subscribe
button to become part of the rod 4 if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and leave a comment down
below let me know if you guys are
interested in something about superior
spider-man I won't guarantee that I'll
do it but I do like to go through the
comments and get an idea of what it is
that you guys are interested in seeing
what it is you guys are not interested
in seeing that kind of thing but with
that being said we're going to bring
this video to an end and I will catch
you guys later
peace